so we've got three functions graphed
here the function f and magenta we have
the function g and this green color and
we have the function h in this dotted
purple color and then we have three
potential expressions or three
expressions that could be potential
definitions for f g and h and what i
want to do in this video is try to match
them try to match the function to a
definition and i'll
i encourage you to pause this video and
try to think about it on your own before
i work through it
so there's a couple of ways that we
could approach this one we could think
about what the graphs of each of these
look like and then think about which of
these functions graphs look like that or
we could look at the function graph and
think about the vertical and horizontal
asymptotes and think about which of
these expressions would have a vertical
or horizontal asymptotes at that point
so i'm actually going to do the second
way let's look at the graphs i tend to
be a little bit more visual or i like to
look at graphs so it looks like f i'll
start with f f looks like it has a
vertical asymptote at x equals five or
sorry at x equals negative five
we have a vertical asymptote right over
here at x
is equal to
negative five let's think about which of
these would have a vertical asymptote at
x equals negative 5. in order to have a
vertical asymptote it can't be defined
there so that's the first way i would
think about it and then even if it isn't
defined there we need to make sure that
it's an actual vertical asymptote and
not just a hole at that point not just a
point discontinuity
so let's let's think about it so this
first expression is actually defined at
x equals negative 5. the only reason why
it wouldn't be defined if somehow we got
a 0 in the denominator but if you have
negative 5 minus 5 that's negative 10.
so this one's defined at that point so
that's not f
this one's also defined at x equals
negative five the denominator does not
become zero so that's not f
this one when x is equal to negative
five this denominator does become zero
so this seems if i just use purely
deductive reasoning this looks like my
best candidate for candidate for f of x
plus confirm that it's consistent with
the other things that we're seeing over
here so let's look at f's horizontal
asymptote if i look at the graph it
looks like there's a horizontal
asymptote especially as x gets to larger
and larger values it looks like f of x
is approaching one
f of x is approaching one now is that
the true is that the same case over here
as
x gets larger and larger and larger as x
approaches infinity
well then the negative 2 and the plus 5
don't matter as x approaches infinity
this is going to approximate for very
large x's it's going to be x over x we
look at the highest degree terms and so
that is going to approach 1 as x gets
very very very large then the negative 2
and the subtracting the 2 in the
numerator and adding 5 in the
denominator are going to matter less and
less and less because the x gets so big
so this will approach 1. so that seems
consistent from that point of view and
let's see is there anything else
interesting well when does this equal
zero well when the new this the
numerator equals zero when x is equal to
two and we see that's indeed the case
for f right over there so i'm feeling
really good that this is our f of x
now let's look at g of x
g of x
has actually they're trying to trip us
up here because it looks like both h and
g of x
have a vertical asymptote at x
at x is equal to 5. so the vertical
asymptote isn't what's going to help us
resolve between g and h all right so i
just say g and f g and h both have a
vertical asymptote at x equals 5. and
you see that over here at x equals 5
both of them
both of them are undefined for when x
equals 5 both of their denominators are
0.
so let's see if the if the horizontal
asymptotes could help us so it looks
like g has a horizontal asymptote at y
equals negative 2.
y equals negative 2.
if x becomes very positive or very
negative it looks like y is approaching
negative 2.
so what's happening up here for this
this top one
well if we expand out the numerator this
is equal to
x
minus 12
over x minus 5.
for very large x's the negative 12 and
the negative 5 aren't going to matter as
much and so this is for very very large
x's this is going to be approximately 2
x over x let me make it very clear 4
maybe i'll write as
as x approaches infinity
and 2 x over x would be 2
would be approximately equal to 2 as x
approaches infinity
g's asymptote isn't at 2 it's at
negative 2.
h is asymptote h is asymptotes the one
that looks like it's at 2 at y equals 2.
so this top one looks like
h of x
this top one looks like an h of x and we
can confirm that when would h of x equal
zero well the numerator equals zero when
x equals six and we see it right over
here now that might have not helped us
that much because g also equals zero
g also equals zero at six but at least
the horizontal asymptotes are what
clueing is what is clueing us in as x
gets really really really large then the
negative the subtracting the 12 in the
numerator subtracting the five and
denominator are going to matter less and
less and less we want to look at the
highest degree terms it's going to
approach 2x over x which is 2 and that
we see that for h
now g
if we if we just use our deductive
reasoning we'd say okay well hopefully
this is our g of x now does this make
sense g of x is equal to 12
minus 2x over x minus 5
but as which is approximately going to
be equal to we look at the highest
degree terms negative 2x over x
negative 2 x over x
as
as x
approaches infinity which is going to be
equal to or we're going to approach
negative 2 and that is indeed where g's
horizontal asymptote is this x gets very
very large we approach negative two or
frankly as x gets very very small where
we're also going to approach negative
two negative two times a negative
billion over a negative billion is also
going to be negative two so we can feel
pretty good that this is our g of x